is kris jenner coming for kylie
cosmetics
what does that mean i'm terrified kylie
let her momager apply her makeup in a
youtube video posted on monday
and she definitely had her concerns not
on the chin
why is there bronzer right here on my
eye because it's it's a new technique
i'm
trying out today could you imagine
standing over picasso
no why are you doing that color here i
am adam picasso would have said
bye honey there were a few mishaps and
we're gonna
do a little model energy right under
the brow that's a little too much
oopsie
sorry but overall chris made sure to
secure that 10
with what she called a glamorous daytime
look i am
pleasantly surprised really could you go
out like this if you had to go run
errands if i
absolutely had to yes chris isn't the
only kardashian jenner who's gotten
ready with kylie
back in 2019 kylie posted a drunk get
ready with me tutorial with her sister
khloe kardashian
we're stirring the pot [ __ ] this is
stirring it with tequila
come to the office and take a shot and
then leave
and things quickly went south when chloe
and kylie took not one
not two but a total of 19 shots of
tequila
i'm gonna use some fatty on the block
blush do you want something that is me
[ __ ]
true mama honestly i'm so proud
should we use it we'd both take an eight
to ten shots
in january kylie turned the tables by
doing kim kardashian's makeup
giving us this hilarious moment i love
a bright inner corner so i like to spray
is not working hold on
[Music]
in 2017 kim told et that since launching
kkw beauty
she's learned so much from kylie i've
always loved beauty she loves beauty
it's her life
i learned so much from her and yeah i
really do
um we just talked she's she's so
like knows what she wants and is in the
field and i'm
um like i love getting her advice on
things
so we work really well together and
there's really no competition
you